this is an alternate version of eggs
meeting Winnie
yes and the idea was that eggs is just
above ground in his disguise and not
knowing what to do and when he is in a
cheese shop being bored while her father
discusses cheese yeah yeah eggs was less
overwhelmed with the world and more just
sort of straight-up curious about it yep
walking around the Market Square
beautiful board from Arab Rascals boards
yeah when he was a little heftier back
in those days in terms of the design she
sees a strange boy walking around eating
cheese wherever he feels like it because
eggs and the whole boxful community they
have no conception of ownership mm-hmm
everything his own community so he just
thinks he can eat and taste anything he
wants to taste you that you have money
to pay for that cheese this was the
first pass at this I mean this whole
story thread was abandoned after one I
mean it would have used quite a few more
versions iterations and rewriting and
stuff to get it to work better I always
liked the idea of these two struggling
over something in the same way that the
to box girls do yeah it is funny too
though I mean for us feisty characters
as when he is in the film this was when
she was even more yeah notes we're not
sure if I like Winnie too much yeah